دعوه للغرق هكذا وصفه المنظمات غير
الحكوميه المعنيه باللاجئين قرار الحكومه
الايطاليه فرق واعد سلوكيه اعلنت ان الهدف
منها تنظيم عمليات الانقاذ تنص مدونه
قواعد السلوك هذه على الالتزام بطلب ميناء
لانزال المهاجرين فورا بعد عمليه الانقاذ
الاولى التي يجب تقديم سرد مفصل عنها فضلا
عن الحظر الضمني على تنفيذ عده مهام اغاثه
وما لم تطلب السلطات الايطاليه لن يسمح
بعد الان بنقل المهاجرين من قوارب
المنظمات غير الحكوميه الصغيره الى قوارب
اكبر
وبمجرد اجراء الاسعافات الاوليه سي يتعين
على السفينه لانتقال الى الميناء الذي
تحدده وزاره الداخليه وفي حاله انتهاك
القواعد الجديده تهدد روما ربا بنت السفن
التابعه للمنظمات غير الحكوميه
بغرامات باهظه كما يمكن ان تصادر السلطات
السفن وتحت تجيزها في الموانئ الايطاليه
القرار اثار غضب منظمات الاغاثه وقالت
منظمه سي واتش الالمانيه التي تنفذ عمليات
انقاذ في وسط البحر الابيض المتوسط
بانتظام ان اجبار السفن على التوجه
للموانئ ينتهك واجب الانقاذ اذا كان هناك
المزيد من الاشخاص في محنه في البحر
وورعدت بمعارضه ما سمته محاوله تجريم
عمليات الانقاذ البحري المدنيه وحرمان
اللاجئين من حقوقهم
مناظمه اطباء بلا حدود انتقدت القرار ايضا
ونقلت صحيفه الاستمتا الايطاليه عن
المسؤولين في المنظمه القول يتم اجبارنا
على ترك من طاقه الانقاذ في البحر الابيض
المتوسط
حمايه مما سيؤدي الى زياده في عدد الوفيات
تصف الحكومه الايطاليه خطواتها بالضروريه
وتعتبر ان من شان الوضع القائم حتى الان
التشجيع على ما تصفه بالهجره غير الشرعيه
والمساعده على اتساع ظاهره الاتجار بالبشر
في عرض البحر المتوسط تمريرات ترفضها
المنظمه غير الحكوميه بشده